okay let's go back to a lot of local
callers this week let's go back to
another caller from the 607 area
caller from 6 1 7 we would love to hear
your name and where you're calling from
and also what your question is today
hello David I'd speak Terry again
I'm calling from dunes Graham I just
want to say I saw your interview with
Dave Rubin yesterday oh yeah can you
hear me yo yeah we can hear you fine
Gary ok so I okay so I saw your
interview with Dave Rubin yesterday and
I remember towards I think it was the
end he was talking about ion here CLE
and how he's how she's a lot better than
Linda Sarsour and well I agree that
Linda Sarsour is somewhat problematic I
just I don't really understand why Dave
Rubin and other people on the right
admire her son so much because I am
literally live to make to start her
political career in the Netherlands and
all that who she says she was from she
was running away as a refugee from
Somalia when it was established that she
had actually left Somalia years before
the Somali civil war began well it's
true that she was a victim of FGM and
all that - I just I don't really
understand why they gave that why they
give people like I am so much leeway
over the fact that she has lied to get
to where she is at now and the fact that
she's really said some pretty messed up
things about odd about how the West
should deal with Muslims at all - I'm
not saying ok I voluntarily closed and
analytics is throwing a lot of stuff out
there look let's see if we can break
this down into its component parts ok so
first of all on the refuge anything and
I don't know that much about her I've
only seen a couple of interviews for
with her and I couldn't possibly tell
you why any other person likes or
dislikes her right I couldn't do that
but just on a couple things so you said
that it's she left Somalia
before there was a bigger exodus of
refugees but you did say that she was a
victim of FGM and presume
of Lee it's not it wasn't a lie that she
did have refugee status right I'm not
sure but I do know that all compared to
what she had said ah in her earlier
statements it basically was later
established odd that she wasn't honest
about why she moved to the Netherlands
it wasn't because of the reason she had
a perlier okay I couldn't unless you
have more information about that I don't
know that for sure it my understanding
is she did have refugee status and thus
I think it would be accurate to say that
she was a refugee although maybe it was
implied that it was based on a later
conflict I don't know okay
as far as the messed up stuff that she
has said about how to deal with Muslims
is there anything in particular that
that was alarming to you well for me I
just I don't really like the fact that
she's really advocated more for the
neoconservative aside and the
neoconservative actions to take on like
odd take on al Qaeda and especially are
that really the kinds of the messed up
u.s. foreign policy that we pursued to
our bring peace to the Middle East I
just I don't think that's a great idea
okay but so really so you have a
political disagreement with her because
she strikes you as neoconservative but
are there any you said she said really
messed up things about how to deal with
immigrants what do you have any examples
of that
ah not off the top of my head but I just
really I don't know I did I just feel
like it she's not I wouldn't be I know
that it but that I do think the left
should respect uh ex-muslims more and I
do think that the way that some people
on the Left try to make expose as
Phaedrus is silly by just I don't think
I understand the best example I think
there's others like Enya aka nice mangos
which I think are better examples to
hold up to by I just don't know I just I
feel like I on your see elites just not
the honest person I just especially when
you compare her
Linda Sarsour okay all right we'll
listen you're entitled to your opinion I
think it's important to distinguish
between you know first you said she's
had some really messed up things and I'm
not saying she didn't but if but it
doesn't sound like at least off the top
of your head you know of any but what it
sounds like you're saying is you think
that there are better examples
politically of X Muslims to follow yes
I'll just what we all right hey Terry
shaking crab and mutant I checked it out
the other day have you ever been there
excellent seafood spot I do know exactly
where Newton is no not offhand it's
right in there though that I know all
right Terry great to talk to you
definitely get the crab legs if you go
and hope to hear from you again